Mic Check 1 2 Mic Check
good afternoon it is my pleasure to
welcome you all to my classroom I am
Julie Ladd and I am a science teacher
here at Helen high I have known governor
Bullock since he and I were in seventh
grade he has been a lifelong friend
since then for the 40 years that have
passed since that time he and I took
several classes together here at HHS one
of which was an advanced biology class
that was taught by my dad
I was his confirmation sponsor and about
11 years ago he presided over my wedding
more than anything I am the reason that
you are here today you see about six
months after Steve moved home from New
York he and I were taking tennis lessons
to the city parks program and at one of
those lessons I mentioned to him that I
had run into an old schoolmate of ours
Lisa downs and I was telling him what a
genuinely kind and wonderful person she
is and I may have encouraged him to call
her and apparently he did and it is my
great privilege to introduce that sweet
kind and wonderful lady to you now Lisa
Bullock
I was impressive Julie I have note I
have the pleasure of introducing Steve
today and I'm filled with two emotions
gratitude and hope Thank You Julie
where'd you go there you are for
bringing Steve and me together for
allowing us to gather in your classroom
today and for using your gifts and
talents to teach and to make a
meaningful difference in the lives of
kids including Caroline's and
congratulations on being nominated I
don't know how many times again for
being a distinguished educator thank you
Thank You principal tennis for allowing
us to gather in your school I know you
had the opportunity to take an
administrative position and thank you
for deciding to follow your heart I know
it meant the world of you too I still
have the opportunity to interact with
students so thank you for using your
talents to impact the lives of all the
students in this school nearly 1,600 of
them thank you thank you to the students
gathered here
I appreciate you accepting Caroline's
invitation
I think the gift of friendship is the
greatest gift you can give to one
another and thank you for giving that
gift to Caroline
these past few years and especially
today and supporting her so thank you
Alex
Caroline and Cameron for supporting your
dad on this journey we recognize that it
makes your life a little bit more
challenging so with that I'm gonna move
on to hope so I hope you guys can feel
connected with Steve today like you he
attended Helena high school
he sat in the same classrooms he walked
the same hallways he cheered in the same
gym I hope that Steve can inspire you to
be courageous each of you has your own
gifts and talents and I hope that you
have the courage to listen to and follow
your heart to attempt to do things even
when people are telling you to pursue
other things or even when others are
telling you that you might fail Alex and
cam are gonna pass out a copy to all of
you of my favorite quote from Theodore
Roosevelt I have it hanging on my wall
at work and I read it every day I hope
that you all have the courage someday or
in the new near future to step into the
arena to dare greatly and to know great
enthusiasm I hope that Steve can inspire
you to serve and to lead even if you
don't know what you want to do yet or
where you want to go to school it's okay
listen to and follow your heart use your
gifts to serve and to lead and to
approve the lives of those around you
and to make where you live study and
work a better place
I know Steve's decision today is
genuinely grounded in making this
country a better place and I know that
he has the courage to use his talents
and gifts to step into the arena to dare
greatly and to know great enthusiasm
please join me in welcoming a man who
continues to inspire me to lead and to
serve Steve Bullock
[Applause]
good afternoon so this morning we
released a video announcing that I was
running to the President of the United
States pretty audacious goal for a beast
due to seeds that you actually said are
sitting in right now but you know I
could think of no better place to kick
it off and right here in this classroom
when I sworn in as governor of Montana
six years ago
I reflected on the improbable journey it
allowed a kid who's raised about a mile
from where we are right now did the
service of 24 governor I noted that what
made the probable achievable it's still
all around us today
the hills surrounded all around little
north of Helena gates and mountains
where I worked
you know it's young it really is sort of
the open of transport places where kids
can explore dream I noted that you could
find him probable right here in these
public schools same schools today
there's given the opportunity to both
realize my potential and then finally
fulfilled that invitation it's extended
no matter your station and you'll find
what made that and problem will
achievable in the values both Montana
values that both my parents in this
community taught us it's respect and
tolerance
it was honest it was hard work most
importantly my mom playing to get us a
good education good open door expand
opportunities give us a chance for
meaningful jobs and then if we chose to
raise our families here as well he's
serving as governor I've had the
opportunity mean tens of house all
across the state share my enthusiasm for
our future and my love of this state we
share the same dreams that my parents
had it really doesn't same dreams that
your parents have for you
the dream that our children will live a
better life and we did the fair shot at
success for every single person I
learned along the way on that journey
there's no matter who you are what you
do or who you voted for most Montanans
we actually want values the one safe
community want a roof over a decent job
good public clean air and clean walk
that unwavering belief you can do better
through kids and grandkids and you ever
had for yourself as well then over my
time not just here in Montana but
the chance to travel quite a bit
throughout this country and it's common
values that we all hold this Montanans
really the same thing that folks really
want to set aside our differences
isn't that ultimately what we need and
move forward as a country to take this
great experiment in freedom democracy
and make it work for every single sense
no matter where they live or how they
work we're losing light love whether
they are born at a ranch in eastern
Montana in downtown Atlanta Chicago
suburbs or small town in Texas because
once we get that really what really
matters it's pretty much the same is
that first we really want just peace of
mind that means a safe place to live and
work enough to eat knowledge that if we
get sick we can't afford medicine
we want clean water to drink space to
move around we get here sure that's just
the basics but if we can actually agree
on these things
that's ultimately how we do it here in
Montana after getting reelected in 2016
our families plan was to complete my
second term as governor and close the
book on this chapter of public service
but what we're experiencing now in this
country compelled us to ask whether
there is more than contribute
fundamentally we've reached I think a
dangerous place and this 243 year
experiment we call representing to Mars
far too many people no longer believe
that they have British our disappearance
the economy works for some but the part
too many people who left behind then
when folks look to Washington DC I think
there's actually reason for skepticism
trust in government visited my life
despite what we learned here in school
our politics are dominated by those who
can actually write the biggest joke and
drown out people's voices and we're
trusting government actually disappears
that's what gives rise to the dangerous
discourse the divisive --mess then you
see everywhere from Washington DC to
every one of your Facebook feeds
government becomes the enemy sever
partner in improving people's lives
will mortify as a country you've ever
been anything in my lifetime each sides
more interested in placing blame
ultimately for what we could come rather
than ultimately inspiring each other to
see how could we be better it's not the
country ultimately that least and I want
to pass on to you which is the next
generation we know that word our best we
actually embrace our shared values not
when we divide into warring camps or
when a fair shot that opportunities
within reach every single thing not just
those with money
we're our best when civility actually
replaces the anger sort of everybody's
voice heard we're willing to take on the
big challenges head-on this place where
you are raised and where I was raised
like you've seen your sister remember
what she's like you got close to
graduation times you're so ready
but Montana at this place it's people
the thrill purpose actually built for
meaning a world worthy probably was
where that unlike review was actually
attainable and those are the same
opportunities
one for each of you because no one
should have to leave their home their
church or community just for a fair shot
but a better life
I've been so blessed and so deeply
honored to be afforded the opportunity
as governor I get back
appreciate you all letting me stop by my
old classroom as we begin to journey
through these next steps to see what we
could be certain the improbable
achievable to make certain that the
country that we hand off to you is
better than the one who's handed off I
can't wait to see what we can do
together
thanks for spent a little time there all
the classrooms would be willing to
answer almost standing question any
questions
what inspired you and president yeah and
it wasn't a thought that I have before
2016 we were or I was really saying
twelve years in the public eyes quite a
bit but after the 2016 election and when
I wanted Montana it was a little bit
unique with the assistance of the state
that present Trump 123 but the level of
division it's not how we do we actually
figure out a way to make things forward
and the knowledge that as I said when I
was growing up here right I said regular
access the governor's house as a kid
because I delivered newspapers to it so
only made it four blocks and
but I'm doing a shot right I had a shot
because I had teachers here to cared
about I had a community that actually
watched out and inspired me heavens
trails that I still go on and I worried
that your generation
like what was supported we need the
opportunity back then 90% of for you
we're doing better than parents with it
today it's only so this idea you work
hard to go to school or you get a train
you're gonna do better
he's out of reach for so many people and
then they look to the political system
for it to work and all these see is not
only dysfunction that seems like us the
most money is who they're gonna pay
attention
I think the economy's kind of broken the
political systems kind of broken and
that's where the bonds between us are so
what inspired me by and large were you
you and everybody else included I can
give this up yep hand off something
better than what I got
yes sir
how would you bridge the political
budget yeah they try to bring them yeah
and that's you know this whole time I've
been governors example right my
legislatures been over about sixty
percent of public but when we walk in
that building that's not who are the
Democrats who are the Republicans on
thought I was like how can we possibly
impact people's lives and I think that
DC can learn a lot from Montana that's I
mean Dave one then I was turning general
course calendar one of the things that
probably more appropriate for your
government class I mean there's this
case citizens united in 2010 it was the
first time Supreme Court's money is
speech and corporations are essentially
so what we've seen is more and more
money being spent outside of elections
to try to influence how people vote used
to be time to like President Bush talked
about the importance of dressing climate
change now out of half wash they won't
even acknowledge the climate changes
human competence so I think step one and
region minified if they actually works a
bit of a lot of the fight of my crew
they're trying to address the outside
dollars and more or less
we can do that by sunset board some
legislation
step two is really what I also said was
recognize worried it's my kid gonna be
it a good school am I gonna be sick
my kids safe when I drop my school and
if we actually look at what you know I
think we can take some that approach in
a way to hopefully will elevate the
system this man
I am happy that hopefully my kids still
know my birth most important job is
being the dad I think the things where
you know as governor it's not like
Attorney General know you won or lost
the case sometimes you did I know that a
hundred thousand people in Montana
health care piece of work that we do I
know that we've done more the earlier
question to try to keep the outside you
two dollars out of our elections so that
your voice matters this long see folks
as long as you follow then some big
corporate Treasury letter company I'm
pleased with the way that we invest in
education I think that's one of the
great equalizers that we have I think
another great equalizer so public lands
we've protected those so we'll handoff
to have to you as well so I guess that's
a few things second please one more
question
oh now you forget it I'm sorry
well you guys should probably have to
judge what my best yeah it is
maybe you know so momma Buffalo is
dropping baby Buffalo off its tool
canary says bye son
on that note
[Music]